[Music]  Holly and Amy you've spent you didn't  know you don't scenes together in the  film but you spent a lot of time  together is that right oh yeah I got to  talk to Holly a little bit and then I  couldn't really talk because I loved her  so much that it's hard and then every  time I love is mutual I do and every  time I talk to her I'm afraid I'm gonna  start slipping into a southern accent  because I want to be her kind of Goblin  Amy you guys got to be really great  French on this right oh my god we really  have to party  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  any one thing you want to elaborate on  the slumber party please Jessie jump in  I just want to make sure they have my  right cell phone number sure sure yes  very nice oh the slumber party was a lot  of fun yeah  you